so now Magnus and myself are going to be
taking on the air things challenge we're
going to play chess but with a Twist all
of the pieces are air things devices we
might be able to rely on pattern
recognition in the first few moves but
we will definitely lose our way uh
somewhere along the lines we also have a
big crowd here so I'm feeling the
pressure let's go
okay I'll stop
oh no
[Music]
thank you
he's too calm I don't like it
oh dear
did not expect that one it's not a very
good move ah it's the Mind Games he's
teasing me already
foreign
way too serious
I really want to win
um okay
yeah it really just looks like you're
moving a pond like a knight
pretty sure that was my night
that's my point
that's my Bishop I'm just always turning
the pieces over to double check
oh wow this is getting uh
crazy now okay I'll try
that is a bishop
does this actually work
you tell me
I'm guessing
I know you're guessing just sometimes
your guesses are right that's the
problem
I've studied this before Magnus
yeah but I mean I can't back down in
this game
that's Brave okay that was a check so
I'm hiding in the corner
[Music]
he's coming another check
this is where it gets
difficult
[Music]
that Queen is too close oh my God I need
like two hours for this position
oh that's just a nice way to lose the
game okay he spotted my trap yeah D4
nice he sees everything yeah
wow
one minute left
yeah I mean I kind of played safe
thank you
now I'm playing like a coward one thing
is I have to play just this way but to
watch this must be
we're so sorry
oh that's tricky
wow that's tricky
he's so tricky
I was hoping for 92 Queen F1
oh my God that was me yeah
okay the game goes on
Queen F4 was open oh that's true okay
well it's missing stuff now 20 seconds
against nine seconds
what do you mean queen of four you mean
air things to add
ah
two seconds oh
gosh
ah
oh my God
what is my
oh I'm losing damn it
oh my God
oh
[Music]
this is a new Queen
if you say so
[Applause]
I think what helped some pieces were
exchanged
early the position was very open I think
that helped a lot like if we played a
closer game it would have been a lot
harder so Magnus beat me in the first
game where we started with five minutes
now I'm gonna try my luck at an even
quicker time control it's two minutes
each let's see how we get on
okay
[Music]
no time to think
no time to die
growing from Big Theory here is this big
theater yet no
I'm not gonna take us
[Music]
effective
oh god what have I done
[Music]
oh I'm such an idiot come on let's do
this
okay
it's too quick you can feel the nerves
in every move now
still it's still much better yeah
I'm definitely mess it up at some point
[Music]
ah
story of my life no time
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
yeah I blended upon and I said I was
it was just some shuffling around and
time ringing out
I need to lie down
okay thank you everyone thank you
next time
[Applause]